THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DID FOR
YOUR COUNTRY TONIGHT.
THIS IS IMPORTANT STUFF.
THANK YOU.
EARLIER TODAY, SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM ISSUES THIS STATEMENT.
NOW, IT'S TIME TO FIND OUT HOW
THIS DEBACLE STARTED.
SENATOR GRAHAM JOINS US ON.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT MULLER HAD
EVERYTHING HE NEEDED TO GET THE
JOB DONE?
EVERYBODY WAS SUCCESSFUL.
MY QUESTION IS, HILARY GETS AWAY
WITH A FIXED INVESTIGATION WHEN
SHE COMMITTED CRIMES?
COULD THEY GET AWAY WITH IT?
THE PEOPLE WHO TRIED TO
INFLUENCE A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, COULD THEY GET AWAY
WITH IT?
OR ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN?
>> I'M MORE DETERMINED TODAY
AFTER THIS HEARING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
THE QUESTION, DID HILARY GET LET
OFF BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE
INVESTIGATING HER WANTED HER TO
WIN AND TRUMP TO LOSE, WAS THE
REASON THAT SHE WASN'T
PROSECUTED.
IT WAS BECAUSE OF POLITICAL
DECISION, POLITICAL MOTIVATION.
ONE THING I CAN TELL YOU AFTER
TODAY, THE MUELLER REPORT IS A
NAME ONLY.
WE'LL SEE, BUT IT CLEARLY WASN'T
THE MUELLER.
IT'S JUST A NAME.
I HAD MORE TO DO WITH THE
MUELLER REPORT THEN PROBABLY HE
DID.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT BOTHERS ME A
LOT?
PEOPLE AROUND MUELLER KNEW HE
WAS IN A WEAKENED STATE.
THIS GUY SERVED IN VIETNAM, GOT
WOUNDED, DID A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS FOR THE COUNTRY.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN CALLED.
>> Sean: SENATOR, LET ME AGREE
WITH YOU.
WHEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AGREED
TO THE STATEMENT,
ATTORNEY GENERAL, I SET AT THE
TIME, HE DID A FAVOR TO BOB
MUELLER.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS WARNING
THAT THIS WAS GOING TO BE A
SPECTACLE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE ONLY PERSON
THAT UNDERSTOOD AND TRIED TO
PREVENTED WAS THE ONE THAT WAS
BEING ACCUSED OF TRYING TO BREAK
BEING ACCUSED OF TRYING TO BREAR
BEING ACCUSED OF TRYING TO BREAG
IT.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
HIS BACKGROUND WAS ONE OF A
HERO.
THE PEOPLE WHO USED HIM, THE
POLITICIANS ON THAT COMMITTEE,
AND THE PEOPLE ON THAT GROUP
THAT HIRED AND DID ALL THIS, AND
HE KNEW NOTHING AND RAN THE SHOW
WITHOUT THEM, THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT DID THIS TO HIS REPUTATION.
>> THE HATRED FOR TRUMP KNOWS NO
BOUNDARIES.
THE REPORT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
I WAS TOLD BY PEOPLE CLOSE TO
BOB MUELLER THAT HE REALLY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THIS.
>> Sean: I KNEW HE WASN'T
CAPABLE OF THIS.
I AM A STUPID TALK SHOW HOST.
I WAS TOLD REPEATEDLY THAT HE IS
NOT UP TO THE TASK.
>> HERE'S THE POINT.
I'VE BEEN ASKED FOR THREE
MONTHS, WHY DON'T YOU WANT TO
CALL MUELLER?
NOBODY WILL ASK ME THAT
TOMORROW.
A LETTER WAS SENT TO ME BY EVERY
DEMOCRAT ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
HERE'S WHAT I WANT TO SAY.
DONALD TRUMP IS STRONGER TONIGHT
THAN ANY TIME IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
THE NEED TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED WAS GREATER THAN IT WAS
BEFORE.
IT'S CLEAR THAT BOB MUELLER WAS
NOT IN CHARGE OF HIS
INVESTIGATION.
WE NEED TO FIND OUT HOW THIS
STARTED.
>> Sean: WE NEED TO SENATOR
SENATOR GRAHAM, THAT CHANGED THE
COURSE OF THE CAVANAUGH HEARING
TO TAKE CONTROL OF THIS.
YOUR COUNTRY NEEDS THIS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THIS REPUBLIC CAME DANGEROUSLY
CLOSE TO ALLOWING LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
YOUR COUNTRY NEEDS YOU.
THAT'S JUST THE FACT.
>> THERE TIME IS COMING.
THE PRESIDENT IS POTOMAC HAS
GONE THROUGH HELL FOR TWO AND
HALF YEARS
>> THEY'VE TRIED TO RUIN HIS
FAMILY'S LIFE.
IT'S THEIR TIME.